twist all the all the tail haha that's
that's what happens the root da troop t1
was played and danced with la takes on
b2 bishop c6
now quit a2 and this pawn will start to
wrong so now it gets really sharp
picture page 5 push a page 5 what is
that
it can react and miss this one Bishop 81
rook P 1 will be 1 so they're playing on
seconds now it's changed and it's
absolutely winning force wiggler now and
Bishop f2 will win in practically
immediately Bishop f2 king F to win
check to b6 it's an extra exchange for
Peter Svidler now so what trauma means
you can't really turn there but but look
I mean this is this is dangerous moment
because Knight gets into play and and we
know how tricky this Knights can be
particularly in a time trouble so Queen
d6 now I'm not catching up I guess I
guess we don't have to look at the board
just on the camera view yeah that's the
here we are 5 citizen cracking is really
low on time he's really long time and
then Peter was about to to swap Queens
but then he realized that those two
connected passed pawns might be a bit
dangerous so he'd better not he pad to
try to hunt White's King well and
Kuryakin managed to build up some sort
of her well not a fortress in percept
but but really set up which will be hard
to break and one I remember the game
which went with the similar scenario
came between Michael Adams and linear
domain guess where Lanier was winning
Linnea was winning pot and sweet leblanc
does the rook and he planted the rook
and and he resigns well so um yeah that
is this is well well crazy contraptions
I mean it was 40 seconds for sweat line
six seconds for kuryakin only yeah and
well no I mean nothing left for them
that's that's absolutely that's a drama
and